hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen in today's what i eat a
day youtuber review
we'll be looking at remy ashton from the
popular youtube channels
miss remy ashton and remlife now
between her two very successful channels
remy has a massive following with around
400 million total subscribers
while she shares everything from diys
shopping hauls and apartment tours
a lot of her recent videos talk about
her weight loss journey
and how she managed to lose and keep off
60 pounds
she also shares that she recently found
out that she has pcos so
i will be keeping that diagnosis in mind
as we go through the review
now before we get into the video a quick
reminder to subscribe
to the channel and ring the bell so that
you don't miss out on any videos
also my general disclaimer that the
information in this video is for
entertainment
and educational purposes only and to
always speak to a healthcare provider
and dietician about your unique needs
also while we do watch an entire work
day's worth of content
we cannot catch a youtuber's entire
catalog
so please keep in mind that what you see
may not fully reflect a full creator's
diet
finally i ask that we be kind in the
comments
both here and on remy's channel let's
keep this
a supportive learning space okay let's
kick things off with her video on what i
in a day to lose weight which
heads up was sponsored by the weight
loss app noom
if you haven't watched my video on noom
i suggest you definitely check it out
right here
and yes i too have been asked to plug
new on my channel
and obviously i respectfully declined
let's see what remy is having as her
pre-workout
i am about to drink some pre-workout
this is the pink guava alani new
pre-workout a scoop of this and then
before i take my pre-workout
i always have a split which is a little
like peanut butter and grape jelly
little mixture
okay so remy is kicking her day off with
a pre-workout supplement
that combines l-citrulline malate
beta-alanine
l-tyrosine caffeine and l-theanine
she's also having a split snack which
contains the good fats from the nut
butter
and some simple carbs from the grape
jelly this is an awesome sounding snack
i mean we've got
carbs protein and fat all in one and
who doesn't love pb and j as for the
pre-workout we do have some research to
support
l-citrulline beta-alanine and caffeine
for activity enhancement
l-tyrosine for responding to stressors
like exercise
as well as a combination of caffeine and
theanine for their synergistic effects
at promoting cognition and attention
these admittedly are not
huge impacts especially for recreational
exercisers
so it may or may not be worth over a
dollar per serving
but hey if remy finds this helps her get
the most out of her workout
i don't think that it necessarily hurts
just a heads up though that i looked up
this brand on
four different third-party testing sites
and i didn't see it
come up so i can't really speak to
whether or not it's being analyzed for
impurities
or accurate labeling but anyways let's
move on to
our breakfast add
cinnamon to my apples and peanut butter
not only does cinnamon taste good but
also it's great to help boost your
metabolism so i made a mess and there's
tons on there but i love
[Music]
okay this looks like a pretty delicious
looking breakfast
you know i love me some everything bagel
spice but
i would say that this is a pretty low
carb
breakfast for a post-workout meal as
ideally we would want to see
a three-to-one carb protein ratio for
optimal recovery
so we could add in another piece of
fruit or pop the hard-boiled egg onto a
slice of bread
lots of options but otherwise we do have
fat
we've got protein we have some fiber
rich carbs
looks pretty good as for her claim that
cinnamon boosts metabolism
this concept really took off a few years
ago when
a study found that exposure to cinnamon
oil increased thermogenesis aka
calorie burning in mice and for humans
but the study actually looked at fat
cells not actual human bodies which
doesn't always translate another study
on
actual humans found that it helped to
reduce the risk of metabolic syndrome
but the dose that they were given was
three grams every day for three months
which is over a teaspoon a day i love
cinnamon
but that is a lot of cinnamon and it's
unlikely that putting a little cinnamon
on your breakfast every once in a while
is going to have any kind of huge
clinical impact
let's take a look at lunch this is a
salad that has chicken
and i think like roasted veggies there's
zucchini there's tomatoes
asparagus avocado there's corn just a
bunch of random vegetables i'm gonna eat
this for
lunch okay so this is another relatively
light
low carb meal we've got a substantial
amount of protein from the chicken
lots of fiber from all of the different
vegetables and some fat from the
dressing
but we are definitely missing our carbs
and
i do know remy is trying to lose weight
but throwing in some chopped sweet
potatoes or berries
or even serving it with a little piece
of whole grain bread or pita
would add in those slow burning carbs
her body is probably really craving
considering that we haven't had a lot
all day
i do however like that she's just
listening to her body and if she doesn't
finish her salad now
she says that she'll finish it later on
and i fill this up like 15 times a day
chug it all day long okay so remy says
that she fills
that water bottle up like 15 times a day
but i do hope that that's like an
exaggeration because
that would mean over 11 liters
yikes if that were true i don't know
that we would see any content from remy
because she would be either drinking
water
or she'd be on the toilet and as a
pregnant person
who spends a lot of time going pee i
cannot imagine that that would be very
fun
and while hydration is of course so
important
remember that there is such a thing as
too much of a good thing
and an excess of water aka hyponatremia
can actually be fatal so i do hope that
the 11
liters isn't her actual water routine
let's take a look at snack it's just a
nectarine
which nectarines are not in season right
now so this one's obviously not that
good it's kind of like hard but a
nectarine during summer when it's really
soft is the best
awesome snack i mean you think that this
girl watches my videos for tips
but we've got a nice combination of fat
fiber-rich carbs and protein
and it's super easy it's fast and it's
satisfying
let's hit up dinner i have my turkey
burger on the lettuce on top of the
turkey burger i did a little
slice of raw red onion some tomatoes and
then the grilled onions on top i have a
few strawberries on the side and this is
going to be
my dinner yum i love a good burger um
but again i'm missing
my carbs and four little strawberries
just
isn't providing very much in fact this
meal as a whole isn't providing a whole
lot with
only 275 calories yes we have a solid
amount of protein
a little fat from the cooking and a
little bit of fiber from some of the
vegetables
but there's definitely room for a whole
grain bun
even a half a bun would give us
something or if not
we could for sure have some more fruit
for dessert
let's take a look at day two
so what we're having i made some banana
chocolate pancakes i was craving
something sweet two scoops of protein
with one
large banana a quarter teaspoon of
baking powder and two eggs topped it
with raspberries some of this
pancake syrup and then an egg avocado
and papaya
hot lemon water okay so this is a
relatively
balanced meal we've got some protein
from the egg and the protein pancakes
carbs and fiber from the berries and
papaya
and some fat from the avocado and egg i
think that there's still room for a
little bit more fruit or piece of toast
so if she was looking to avoid the added
sugar by using the zero calorie syrup
she could also like
mash some raspberries with some chia
seeds to make a little chia jam
i will leave my super popular recipe
below if you're looking for some
inspiration
but let's take a look at lunch
kale then i massaged with some olive oil
some leftover sweet potatoes from last
night quarter of an avocado one shallot
thinly sliced
i mixed some of that vegan garlic dip
with water to thin it out and use it as
a dressing
pepper red chili flakes and some crushed
almonds this looks like a delicious
salad and i love that it's plant-based
we've got a good amount of fat from the
olive oil nuts avocado and the garlic
dip
a little carbs from the sweet potato veg
from the kale
and bits of protein from here and there
now in a perfect world
i would say for the amount of fat which
is largely really healthy fat and
probably really satiating
i would also love to see you know a bit
more carbs and if we want to
focus on this meal specifically the
protein is
also a little low but since we had a
really protein heavy breakfast
in the context of her day protein is
definitely
not a concern for me i do think that
there's space for a little complex
carbs with some you know throw in some
quinoa or some more sweet potatoes
or adding in an extra piece of fruit but
let's see what else she has to say you
guys have never tried liquid iv
i am such a fan of it basically if you
put it into like a 16 ounce glass of
water
it gives you the same amount of
hydration as if you were to drink three
bottles of water so that's really cool
i'm super stoked to try this flavor and
i cannot wait to try it
okay so according to remy and liquid
ivy's website
this yummy product apparently triples
the hydration factor
by utilizing cellular transport
technology
a trademarked term of course now the
theory
is based on the fact that added sodium
potassium
and sugar into the water helps create an
osmotic
force to deliver fluids to your
bloodstream faster
this is based on the who's guidelines
for oral rehydration solutions used in
developing countries
so it's not like the science isn't sound
but it's not necessarily that one bottle
of water
magically becomes the equivalent of
three
if you look at the fine print it's
actually just that it may provide
hydration
two to three times faster this may be
really important in third world
countries
in the heat but i don't really
understand what remy needs this
super speedy hydration for especially
because these will cost you about two
dollars per serving
even if it did give you three times the
hydration
water in america is free right
anyways i'm just teasing if you love it
girl you love it
let's take a look at dinner the taste of
them so i have two different brands here
this is the thrive market this is
miracle noodle they're both fettuccine
so we're gonna do that with some ground
turkey i'm currently sauteing up some
onion i think i'm gonna make it sort of
like a
basilly creamy sauce
okay so i'm definitely glad we've got
some protein from our turkey and
nutritional yeast
some fat for cooking in and the garlic
sauce and lots of fiber rich veg from
the mushrooms onion
and spinach you know i'm not into
cutting out full food groups so
i do think that there's definitely room
for some actual noodles
or a piece of bread for like sopping up
that extra garlicky sauce
but it seems like she actually really
enjoys these share tacky noodles
and this doesn't feel necessarily
restrictive to her you know
at least she is getting a good amount of
fiber and isn't compensating with
crazy protein portions or saturated fats
so if a lower carb diet works for remy
then it works for me
a quick note on the sheer tacky noodles
which as remy says is an acquired taste
and one that i have not acquired
personally
but basically these are long noodles
made from a fiber called
glucomannan and water some versions also
have a little tofu or other flowers
but all of them are really low in
calories i mean this one has just 40
calories
and just four grams of carbs per bag now
aside from potentially helping with
calorie cutting because they are
so low in calories and fiber rich
glucomannan fiber
has also been shown to help delay
stomach emptying
which allows blood sugar and insulin
levels to rise more gradually
and evenly so while this may have
benefits for people with pcos and with
insulin resistance in general
i don't believe that you need to go carb
free
to lose weight or even to manage your
pcos
i actually discuss this in a little bit
more detail at the end of this video
so skip forward if you want to see but
you should also
check out my video on pcos and dieting
here
again if this is a food remy truly
enjoys and doesn't feel restrictive
then i don't see this as a big deal
let's take a look at day three
and in this video it's basically less of
a legit
wedding day video and more of a
collection of meals
that remy has put together morning
through night
that she says has helped her lose weight
so let's take a look
okay guys there you have it my protein
coffee for breakfast
it's seriously so good okay i'm not sure
if she's suggesting that this
combination of just protein powder and
coffee
is a breakfast option for losing weight
but with just over 100 calories
i wouldn't call this breakfast at all i
mean this would be great with some fruit
or a piece of toast with some nut butter
but all on its own it's just straight up
protein
plus some artificial sweeteners and
stimulant i would maybe do this as a
post workout
but even still i would want to pair it
with some fruit
oatmeal or toast let's see her weight
loss lunch idea
potato slices with the tuna salad and my
avocado toast
absolutely no miss ramyashi meal will be
complete with without any crushed red
pepper and of course
everything but the bagel seasoning
there's avocado on everything in my life
okay so this looks pretty good
we've got lots of healthy fats from the
avocado protein from the egg and tuna
some fiber rich veg and some carbs from
the bread
and that's actually one of my favorite
breads because it's fiber rich
and really hearty now of course i think
there's room for a second
slice for her tuna salad if she wanted
it but there is still at least 40 grams
of carbs here so
it's not keto low and with her pcos
diagnosis
the combination of the fiber-rich bread
with lots of healthy fats and protein
is a great way to manage those blood
sugars let's check out dinner
it did it up it looks so good this looks
like it's straight up from a ramen bar
at this futakake japanese multi-purpose
seasoning can we focus that is our
veggie filled
zero calorie ramen okay so we've got a
whopping
40 grams of protein here from the
chicken and egg
fat from the oil and sesame seeds and
lots of fiber-rich veg
i'm sure this is really sweet shading
and i love me a big bowl of ramen
having said that it is pretty low in
carbs
and pretty high in protein with about 20
grams and 40 grams respectively so
if she wanted to throw in some high
fiber sweet potato or do half
and half sheer tacky and whole grain
noodles she could totally do it without
being an issue for her pcos
again if remy really likes the water
noodles and she finds that the extra
protein
at dinner helps her with her weight loss
or she would rather sneak in some
more carbs with dessert that counts as
solid balance in my books as well let's
take a look at dessert
i'm a friend when you get a taste of oh
the salt
that's pretty good that was really good
good job definitely going to freeze them
a little more
the salt is so good put salt on top
those look so good and i actually have
recipes on my blog
for homemade twix and snickers bars so
i'll definitely leave some links to that
below
but i love that remy is freestyling this
recipe and also that we've got some
healthy fats and a little fiber and
protein from the almond flour
to really balance out the natural sugars
in those dates and dark chocolate
i mean for those of you who don't want
to make a chocolate bar from scratch i
also think that there's nothing wrong
with having an
actual twix bar too especially in the
context of remy's dinner which was
so rich in fiber protein and healthy
fats
but for a more balanced everyday sweet
that looks
great alright so we've made it through
the meals
now for the big question is this way of
eating balanced
so according to my calculations remy is
consuming between 1350 calories
and 1550 calories a day eating a
relatively
lower carb higher fat high protein diet
i get that she is on a weight loss
journey while also trying to manage her
pcos
but i would worry that especially on
days that she's working out
this just might not be enough fuel
if we look at the body of research on
the low carb versus low fat debate
we can see why more people are
gravitating towards
the former while there are a lot of
large studies that suggest there's no
statistical differences in weight loss
over time between
a low carb and a low fat diet others do
show
more weight loss with low carb diets
along with other improvements in other
lab values like blood sugar
and blood cholesterol levels this is
likely because fat and protein are just
more satiating than carbs
particularly those that are higher in
the glycemic index or
lower in fiber the downside is that a
lot of these studies take place over
relatively limited time frames and
compliance
is generally poor in other words we
really don't know how sustainable these
diets truly
are the few that we do have that are a
bit longer
generally show that weight loss tends to
even itself off
at around the one year mark so there
really isn't a huge difference between
low-fat and low-carb diets it's mainly
just like a personal preference
also if the evidence on weight regain is
any indicator
i think it's safe to assume that weight
cycling or yo-yo dieting
is always a major concern specifically
in the context of pcos
i know it's often recommended that
people with pcos avoid
or reduce carbs or go on restrictive
diets to manage their symptoms
but as i talked about with my colleague
julie duffy dillon in this video here
these recommendations often can do more
harm than good
by increasing cortisol testosterone and
a pro-inflammatory state through weight
cycling
that is already heightened with pcos
interestingly in a video released right
before the video where remy addresses
her pcos diagnosis
remy talks about how she gained weight
back over the holidays
from less strict adherence to her diet
but the silver lining
was that she actually got her period
back this may be a sign
that the calorie-restricted
carb-restricted diet that remy has been
using to lose 60 pounds may have caused
or be causing
some hormonal dysregulation now i'm not
saying that losing 60 pounds to a lower
carb or
lower calorie diet was bad for remy's
pcos or general health
it may in fact be beneficial i mean that
is not for me to judge
i don't have her lab work i'm not her
endocrinologist
what is healthy for one person may be
unhealthy for another
but this is just a message for all of my
viewers particularly those with pcos
that managing your health does not
necessarily require restriction
or massive weight loss i'm a big
believer
in an additive approach to food rather
than always focusing on
removing foods both with weight loss and
with pcos management
and for a lot of people just adding a
source of fat or protein
to a carb rich meal that you love is a
lot more sustainable
and a more balanced approach having said
all of that
the two biggest concerns that i have
with the general public
going super low carb is a sustainability
and the risk of it resulting in some
kind of binge
from restriction and b not getting
enough antioxidants and fiber
restriction wise i don't hear a lot of
negative discussion around food
it sounds like she's just choosing foods
that she enjoys
and with the exception of some cheat day
behavior which i will discuss
momentarily
it doesn't really sound like she's
starving herself or that this
restriction is impacting her quality of
life
and nutrition wise based on the foods
that she's choosing
i'm not really particularly concerned
about fiber or antioxidants either
in fact the few nutrients of concern i
did see in her analysis
were vitamins d3 omega-3s and iron
all of which largely come from fat rich
foods
not carbohydrates so if she isn't
already she may want to consider a
supplement
or just upping her intake of foods
fortified with d3
fatty fish flax or chia or adding more
fish
beans lentil tofu or dark leafy greens
for extra iron
this may also help her just add more
variety to her protein rotation
as i'm seeing mainly just poultry and
eggs
so unless there's an intolerance that i
just didn't catch i definitely think
that there's some room for
some more fish and some plant-based
options as well
i did shoot this video a while ago so i
revisited her channel to see how her
eating may have changed
and while it was still relatively low in
carbs
some of her vlogs did include a little
bit more carbs in her meals
from things like chickpea pasta sushi
with rice
protein oatmeal and avocado toast
so it sounds like she's finding a way of
eating that is sustainable to
her which is great now are there any
problematic claims on this channel
nothing major i'm seeing i mean yes a
lot of remy's content
is weight loss focused but she also
often acknowledges that
she's not an expert and is just sharing
her journey and
most importantly the tips that she does
offer
are relatively benign she's not telling
her followers to purposefully starve
themselves
she's not telling anyone about dangerous
cleanses or super problematic
supplements for the most part i think
her weight loss method comes down to
physical activity reducing calories and
keeping her carbs
relatively low but not keto but of
course if you find weight loss content
triggering
then for sure this channel is just not
for you
i will say that in watching her channels
i heard the word
clean more times than i would have liked
but you know
i do fully acknowledge that this is just
so deeply ingrained in our culture
it is a hard word to unlearn i also have
seen a lot of cheat days on her channel
which i think speaks to the problem with
dieting in general
but more specifically may suggest that
remy's diet
may be just too restrictive to sustain
does that mean
that if you want to lose weight you
should never have a day of eating more
than you would
normally or more sugary or more fatty
foods than usual
no not at all like there's one video
where she's having a
cheat day at disney world i would also
want to try out
all the fun fair foods at disney even if
those were not part of my usual diet
but often by labeling these days as
cheat days
even just in your own mind we throw
ourselves
into a restrict binge cycle that just
doesn't feel good
not physically and not emotionally
either that may not be an issue for remy
and
i will say that her cheat days are not
as extreme
as a lot of the eating challenges that
i've discussed on my channel previously
but now just knowing her pcos diagnosis
i would really urge her to take a more
balanced approach
allowing herself to have more of these
beloved treats peppered throughout her
diet
especially if paired with a source of
fiber or healthy fats or protein
may help her better manage her condition
in the long run and finally
what good can we take away from remy's
channels well
honestly i love remy i just do i mean
she's
she's fun she's funny and has an insane
amount of infectious energy so
i can see why she has such a huge
following i think her recipes are also
really simple
and accessible and ultimately look
really good
with the exception of the protein powder
pre-workout
the iv thing and the share tacky noodles
which are really not hard to find in
2020
her meals are based around ingredients
that most of us
have at our home and despite trying to
lose weight or maintain her weight loss
she actually has a relatively laid back
approach to food
i haven't seen her weigh out every
strawberry or use a ton of
really diety sugar-free fat-free foods
with the exception of the sugar-free
syrup
she cooks with modest amounts of oil and
prepares sauces and recipes
without measuring every little thing out
that is kind of refreshing to see in the
weight loss space i'm also not seeing
massive overwhelming portions of lettuce
seasoned with sugar-free syrup and hot
sauce juxtaposed against
10 000 calorie challenge videos so i
think that even within the context of
weight loss
she's a pretty healthy role model for a
lot of young girls
bottom line i really really like remy's
channels so
i'm glad that you guys all introduced me
to her content
i think it's nice to see a youtuber
whose whole identity
is not wrapped up in weight loss or
their appearance
or specific way of eating and that she
has a lot of
really super fun aspects of her life to
share as well
well folks that is all for today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
you